هذه ليست كرة شعر سعلتها القطة ،
أوه لا ،
هذه قطعة كبيرة من شعر إلفيس ،
قطعة كبيرة بحجم كرة القاعدة لم يتم جمعها
خلال أشهر قصة شعر له ، فقد
شعره للجيش ، لكن قيل إنه
جمعه بواسطة حلاقه.  أكثر من عقدين من
الزمن تم
الاحتفاظ بها في كيس بلاستيكي تم نقله إلى
جرة محكمة الغلق
وبيعها الآن مقابل
72500 بواسطة مزادات Cruz gws
مع وثائق مثل جميع تذاكر الطائرة التي
حصل عليها إلفيس لحلاقه ليصطحبه إلى
العروض التي بيعت بها ماكينة حلاقة الملك الكهربائية أيضًا
مقابل 3  ألف دولار لكنها
مليئة بالمال ، حيث تم دفع ما يزيد قليلاً عن
مليون دولار مقابل
ما يسمى ببدلة الجزيرة وحرب الرأس إلفيس
لأداء في ماديسون سكوير غاردن ،
لقد فقدت إلفيس هيربول القيمة
التي بيعت لأكثر من مائة وخمسة عشر
ألفًا  الدولارات في المرة الأخيرة التي تم
بيعها بالمزاد العلني منذ ما يقرب من 20 عامًا في
ذلك الوقت ، كان هناك حديث عن إمكانية استخدام الحمض النووي
في الشعر
كأساس لمحاولة معقدة للغاية
لاستنساخ الأسطورة
ولكن عقدين من الزمن  s لاحقًا ، ما زال إلفيس غير موجود
في المنزل ،
لقد غطيت العطاءات للحصول على
كتل أصغر من شعره ، لذا كيف يبدو
الأمر عندما تمرر يديك من خلال شعر إلفيس ، إنه
مثير للغاية المارد حقًا
وصفته بأنه خشن وليس ناعمًا من
اشترى هذا الشعر الأخير  الكرة ، أنت أفضل
كما يقول إلفيس ، عاملني بلطف ،
وحك ظهري ، وقم
بتشغيل أصابعي الجميلة القديمة في رأسي
المارد
cnn نيويورك